today's new member of the day is dr.
Marlene soul Gruber dr. Marlene soul
Gruber thank you for being a supporter
of the show I also want to thank Michael
O'Brien who is today's longtime
sustaining member of the day with us
almost 5 years dr. Marlene and Michael
thanks to both of you we are going to be
sending out just a blockbuster massive
this is gonna get Trump tweeting fake
news it's so crazy membership special on
my birthday on February 2nd if you want
to be notified about that membership
discount get on our mailing list at
david pakman.com and on february 2nd you
will be notified here's how to take
advantage of this offer that is so good
you might think it's fake news and no
gifts please just sign up for membership
that's all I'm asking for for my
birthday this year
okay it's time for hatred mail quick
reminder about what hatred mail is and
then I've got a special hatred mail
announcement for you momentarily here
we're so all right it's wrong patriot
mail written by Patriots who hate David
Pakman because America and because
freedom so we've made an investment in
hatred mail 4 years now hatred mail has
had the same backing track for the
hatred messages along with hatred mail
guy we procured license licenses for
some additional backing tracks and I
think that they kind of add an entire
new layer of nuttiness and wackiness to
hatred mail so today with today's
episode of hatred mail we're debuting
one of the new backing tracks let's take
a listen to it oh wow a Jew denying the
idea of deep States what a coincidence
oh the deep state runs Washington
massage not a secret Park man it's not
even news Oh
David you're so clever and trying to
cover your tracks
but we all know yeah
so the typical anti-semitism of hatred
mail of course Jews like me would deny
the existence of the deep state because
Jews are a big part of the deep state
not a surprise but that that music pad
that really is a whole new element to
hatred mail isn't it yeah it's an
exciting time to be alive
and of course the hatred here struggled
to spell the word your there are
different spellings and uses of the word
your so I can see how that can happen
so he just abbreviated yr that works for
me yeah a common error in hatred mail is
why oh you are instead of Y oh you
apostrophe re this hatred completely
circumvented it by just replacing it
with the word yr and that is certainly a
way to avoid the your you are confusion
for sure
we have a coupon code hey tree at 40 if
you use that code when you get a
membership on our website you will save
40% and many many hey tree it's cry
every time that coupon code is used
because it just shows the backfire of
their angry ranting so use that coupon
code h 80 are IOT 42 discount the
membership of your choice at WWJ in
pakman.com